The Marvel Cinematic Universe is a complicated
place where just about everything is way more
important than it initially seems — including
dialogue.
These are some of the most significant exchanges
that slipped by audiences at the time, only
to leave a major impact on them later on.
In Avengers: Infinity War, Tony Stark confronts
Thanos on Titan, only to be addressed by name.
When he asks if the Mad Titan knows him, Thanos
responds:
"I do.
You're not the only one cursed with knowledge."
The line is clearly dripping with deeper meaning,
but the obvious question is, how does Thanos
know Tony Stark?
The commentary track for the movie answered
that question when screenwriter Christopher
Markus explained:
"You realize this interesting parallel between
Thanos and Tony.
They're both aware of something from an early
point and constantly having to deal with being
smarter.
Thanos is a futurist as much as Tony Stark."
The connection between the two, while it has
its limits, certainly explains why the Mad
Titan would gravitate toward Stark as a fellow
being that struggles with the "big issues."
But what about the fact that he addressed
him by name?
Co-director Joe Russo cleared that one up
by explaining that Thanos is, quote, "aware
of Stark from the original Battle of New York
as the person who undid the plan."
This double whammy of Stark initially getting
Thanos' attention with a nuke and then connecting
with him as a fellow genius certainly goes
a long way in explaining why the Mad Titan
would have such respect for his opponent.
Phase one of the MCU was a formative time
as many of the basic elements and unofficial
laws of how things work were established and
fleshed out.
One of those "unofficial laws" has to do with
the difference between magic and science,
and it's initially laid out by Thor during
his first solo outing.
At one point in the movie, the God of Thunder
and Jane Foster have a conversation in which
Thor explains that …
"Your ancestors called it magic, and you call
it science.
Well, I come from a place where they are one
and the same thing."
The line, uttered while the two characters
are making eyes at one another, is deceptively
important under the surface and ends up being
a huge mantra going forward.
It doesn't matter if you're dealing with Infinity
Stones, vibranium from Wakanda, or pretty
much anything Doctor Strange does most "magical"
moments are eventually explained away in scientific
terms at some point or another.
Whatever the situation, there's no doubt at
this point that the overlap between science
and magic has firmly embedded itself as one
of the MCU's guiding principles.
At one point in Avengers: Age of Ultron, Tony
Stark and Bruce Banner are seen discussing
a new form of artificial intelligence recovered
from Von Strucker's HYDRA-backed research.
The two debate as Stark insists that he wants
to harness the potential power of the AI in
order to run his Iron Legion as a form of
protection for the world.
Remember, this all takes place after the group
defends Earth from an invasion of Chitauri
aliens in Avengers.
It also comes after Stark is given a disturbing
vision by Scarlet Witch in which he sees death
and destruction brought on by another galactic
attack.
At one point in the conversation, Stark says:
"I see a suit of armor around the world."
The line slips by fairly quickly and is mostly
forgotten after Ultron emerges and becomes
a threat.
But the idea of a global "suit of armor" as
protection against extraterrestrial threats
never quite disappears.
In fact, Stark's dream of defending the Earth
becomes a primary theme in his gradually unfolding
showdown with Thanos, as the Iron Avenger
attempts to do everything in his power to
stop the Mad Titan.
The relationship between Natasha Romanoff
and Clint Barton is legendary at this point.
But it's never on better display than it was
during the airport fight scene in Captain
America: Civil War.
As all the heroes split off and fight each
other, who should find themselves face to
face but the pair of ex-S.H.I.E.L.D. agents.
They engage in a pleasantly entertaining,
comparatively low-energy duel that's interrupted
when Scarlet Witch tosses Black Widow aside
and calls out Barton for, quote, "pulling
his punches."
Initially, Barton gains the upper hand and
pins his opponent to the ground, at which
point this exchange goes down:
"We're still friends, right?"
"Depends on how hard you hit me."
The scene is a lighthearted break from the
serious events of the film and showcases the
enduring friendship of the duo.
However, it isn't until Avengers: Endgame
that the gravity of those lines really hits
home.
When Romanoff and Barton head to Vormir, it
turns out that their love for each other is
exactly what is needed in order for Black
Widow to give her life in order to gain the
Soul Stone an event that also involves some
hard hitting as they fight over who will make
the sacrifice.
One of the best sequences in the entire MCU
takes place during Thor's time on Sakaar in
Thor: Ragnarok.
Each scene is filled with tongue-in-cheek
slapstick humor as Thor, a.k.a. Sparkles,
finds himself trapped by the Grandmaster and
forced to fight his champion.
Fortunately, that champion ends up being none
other than Thor's old friend and co-Avenger,
Hulk.
Thor's reaction, when he sees the Jade Giant
enter the arena, is priceless.
His look of concern melts away as he cheers,
adding …
"Hey!
Hey!
We know each other!
He's a friend from work!"
It's already one of the funniest lines in
the entire movie, which is saying something.
But the background behind how it came into
being makes it even better.
It turns out the line wasn't invented by the
writers, director, or even Thor star Chris
Hemsworth.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Hemsworth explained that what is arguably
the most iconic line from the entire movie
was actually thought up by a child from the
Make-A-Wish Foundation, who was on the set
when they filmed the scene.
Priceless.
When Thanos plucks the Mind Stone out of Vision's
head in the waning moments of Infinity War,
his victory seems both imminent and inevitable.
That is, until Thor suddenly arrives, hurling
Stormbreaker at the unsuspecting villain and
catching him off guard.
The weapon strikes him in the chest, and Thor
drops down in its wake in order to gloat in
his apparent victory.
But of course, we all know what happens next:
"You should have gone for the head."
"NOOO—"
While the repercussions of that line are pretty
obvious, there's one hidden side effect that
isn't quite so easy to spot.
Obviously, Thor's choice to prioritize his
own gloating over simply killing Thanos on
sight meant half of the universe perished
and all of the pain and loss of Avengers:
Endgame had to follow.
But another unexpected result came in the
form of Thor's physical appearance and dejected
condition in the fourth Avengers film.
In the beginning of the movie, Thor ends up
"going for the head," decapitating a helpless
Thanos in a fit of angry vengeance.
But, as writers Markus and McFeely pointed
out, that very action turns out to be a failure
that breaks his will completely.
"Are you crying?"
"No…….
yes."
One of the most iconic lines from Marvel Comics
is "Avengers assemble!"
The phrase was anxiously anticipated throughout
the first Avengers film but never surfaced.
In Avengers: Age of Ultron, it became clear
that director Joss Whedon was playfully avoiding
the line.
After all, how can we forget that ending?
"Avengers…"
All of which serves to underscore why it was
a pretty big deal when, at the climax of his
Avenging career, Captain America finally,
at long last, uttered those two words before
the decisive battle at the end of Avengers:
Endgame.
Surrounded by a host of heroes who had just
joined him at the last second via a myriad
of sling rings, it was the absolute perfect
time for the phrase to finally find its way
onto the big screen.
"Avengers… assemble."
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 is a fun trip
that follows the Guardians team as they grow
closer as a family.
It also introduces Mantis, reboots Groot as
Baby Groot, and sees Yondu pull a Mary Poppins.
It also ALSO has an important teaser at the
very end of it all in the form of a new character.
One of the film's end credits scenes shows
Ayesha, the High Priestess of the Sovereign,
as she is about to be held accountable by
the Sovereign Council for wasting resources.
She has one last trick up her sleeve as she
admires an elaborate golden birthing pod that
rests before her.
What's inside?
According to Ayesha:
" … the next step in our evolution.
More powerful, more beautiful, more capable
of destroying the Guardians of the Galaxy."
She goes on to come up with a name for this
new being...
"I think I shall call him…
'Adam.'"
The person being referenced is the powerful
Adam Warlock, a comic book character that
Marvel fans have been hoping to see for quite
a while now.
Chances are we'll see Warlock sooner rather
than later, as Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is
officially on the docket.
Not only that, but James Gunn is back to helm
the project, giving Warlock an even greater
likelihood of getting in on the action he's
a favorite character of the director.
"I am Iron Man."
Four simple words.
At this point, we've got pretty used to hearing
them, but when one stops to think about their
impact on Tony Stark's storyline, not to mention
the MCU as a whole, it's a bit staggering.
Right from the get-go, Tony Stark was drawn
toward the phrase, uttering it during his
first solo outing to the amazement of a room
full of reporters.
The line shows up again in Iron Man 3, this
time expanded:
"You can take away my house, all my tricks
and toys.
One thing you can't take away?
I am Iron Man."
The words are a rallying point for Stark's
identity.
They're a way to sum up his entire persona.
It's also a concept that comes to its ultimate
fruition at the very end of the Infinity Saga.
After all the dramatic events in the war with
Thanos, as he kneels, with the Infinity Stones
in hand and his fingers ready to snap away
the Mad Titan's entire existence, what four
words does Stark choose to use?
You've heard 'em before:
"I am Iron Man."
In the early moments of Captain America: The
First Avenger, the Red Skull is shown leading
a raid on a Norwegian village in search of
the Tesseract.
The cube, secretly containing an Infinity
Stone, ultimately ends up going on to play
a key role in Captain Marvel's origin story
before it's used by both Thanos and the Avengers
during the events of Infinity War and Endgame.
But it doesn't take those world-shaking events
for the Nazi villain to understand what he
has in his possession.
As he stands looking at the stone in amazement,
Red Skull simply utters:
"And the Fuhrer digs for trinkets in the desert."
The line could very well be a reference not
only to Hitler's fascination with the occult
but it could also be an homage to the Indiana
Jones movies, which feature Nazis searching
for both the Ark of the Covenant and the Holy
Grail in the desert.
Do Indy's adventures secretly take place within
the MCU?
Well no.
Duh.
But either way, referring to an artifact that
can obliterate your enemies as a "trinket"
is a pretty bold way to let savvy audience
members who picked up on the line know that
they're dealing with some pretty powerful
stuff.
Captain America: The First Avenger ended up
being a critical part of the MCU, as it set
in motion one of the most important storylines
of the entire Infinity Saga.
The story traced Steve Rogers on his path
from a physically weak, morally strong young
man to a full-blown super-soldier with the
weight of the world on his shoulders.
But, for all of the heroics, one of the best
lines in the entire film wasn't about Rogers
the superhero as much as Rogers the romantic.
As the film's World War II action wraps up,
Rogers wakes up nearly 70 years in the future,
having spent the last several decades in an
ice-induced coma.
Bewildered, the hero runs out into a bustling
city street and is confronted by none other
than Nick Fury, who informs him of how long
he's been asleep.
He looks around, taking in the shocking news
that everything he ever knew lies three-quarters
of a century in the past.
Fury asks Steve is he's OK to which Rogers
responds:
"Yeah.
Yeah, I just…
I had a date."
This, of course, is a reference to his romantic
relationship with Peggy Carter, which had
so suddenly been cut off.
While the line was moving on its own, it ultimately
meant quite a bit more when Avengers: Endgame
rolled around.
At the end of that film, Rogers heads back
in time, blowing past his timestamp in order
to finally, at long last, fulfill that date
with Agent Carter.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.